bon on passe à un autre sujet qui n'a
rien à voir ce week end
l'écrivain yann moix a tenu des propos
comme moi je considère comme détestable
mais c'est un point de vue après tout
c'est le nom de cette émission sur les
policiers propos qu'on vous fera part il
entend d'ailleurs parce que on n'a pas
trop envie de l'est de la publicité à ce
monsieur
en revanche je voudrais s'arrêter sur le
fond du sujet qu est ce qu a dit moi que
s'il a dit les ce sont les policiers qui
ont peur
aujourd'hui alors que il devrait
intégrer cette peur est sous-entendu
c'est cette inquiétude n'est pas
légitime
écoutez ce que lui répond stanislas
godon c'est l'un des principaux patrons
des syndicats étudiants des syndicats
étudiants mais policiers puisqu'il est
secrétaire national de ce syndicat
alliance et ils étaient ce matin chez
bfm tv que c'est une insulte aussi aux
430 policiers par mois qui sont blessés
aux sept policiers tués l'année dernière
et c'est une insulte aussi au travail au
quotidien de nos collègues qui oeuvrent
dans des quartiers souvent difficiles où
on n'hésite pas comme à viry châtillon a
jeté des cocktails molotov a brûlé des
policiers
merci d'ailleurs ensemble les policiers
un peu gêné parce que effectivement il
ya de plus en plus de pression sur eux
les ya de plus en plus de violence et en
même pas comme ils sont les forces de
l'ordre ils peuvent pas vous et cette
faiblesse ou cette crainte ou cette peur
clairement il ya un sujet de respect des
forces de l'ordre qui n'a pas été ce qui
n'a pas été le cas dans les baux deviens
moi que ça des propos qui sont
absolument inacceptables et élus guerre
c'est vrai qu'on a cette difficulté de
la part des policiers a exprimé la
difficulté qu'ils peuvent avoir aller
dans certains quartiers intervenir
effectivement et ça c'est une réalité
par rapport à l'affirmation qui leur
nécessité
20 la nécessité qu il alors d'affirmer
leur pouvoir et leur capacité de
protéger les populations et de faire
respecter l'ordre donc c'est vrai que
cet avis elle est consubstantielle alors
à leur profession avec eux quand elle
arrive comme ça dans le débat public par
des par des polémiques aussi aussi vive
ça rend extrêmement difficile le travail
d'explication plausible à nos confrères
journalistes john publie un livre qui
sape sur les policiers qui s'appelle la
peur a changé de camp
c'est à dire sous-entendu aujourd'hui ce
sont les policiers qui ont peur c'est
une caractéristique de l'époque donc je
pense que c'est un titre pour faire
vendre mais je pense pas que ce soit une
réalité
d'abord que des policiers et peur se
trouve ça normal
est ce que ça veut dire pour autant
qu'ils sont pas courageux
qu'ils ne pourront pas maîtriser leur
stress ça veut peut-être dire simplement
qu'ils sont lucides mais ça ne veut pas
dire qu'ils ne vont pas faire
correctement leur métier
on a le droit d'avoir peur vous croyez
qu'un soldat au mali il a jamais peur
quand il part
l'opération ça veut dire quoi ce
discours ces espèces de surhomme ça
pourrait dire qu'ils sont aussi
totalement inconscient et qui pourrait à
ce moment là faire n'importe quoi par
ailleurs il ya quelque chose qu'il faut
dire aussi c'est que beaucoup de gens
qui se trouvent en banlieue parmi les
policiers ce sont de très jeunes
policiers des gens qui sortent de
l'école on va mettre des renforts
prochainement parce qu'il a fallu le
temps pour les former mais c'est des
gens qui n'ont pas d'expérience très
souvent d'ailleurs et viennent de
petites villes ou d'un milieu rural et
connaissent pas la banlieue sous ils
savent pas quoi ça ça après cela
correspond et ils ont un certain nombre
de représentations dont kylie halak je
crois à une situation qu'il faut qu'il
faut prendre en compte
je pense que ce sont des gens qui font
remarquablement leur métier dans
certaines situations extrêmement
difficiles et que on y mettrait des gens
guérissent et un peu comme les
professeurs dans les collèges vaudrait
mieux mais il met ceux qui ont un peu
d'expérience que de mettre ceux qui
viennent d'avoir le capes ou l'agreg
mais cela ils sont pas beaucoup de
points donc il ils ont rien le droit de
dire et c'est là qu'ils vont aller ceux
qui ont plus de bouteille et ben ils
vont pouvoir mieux choisir les endroits
où ils vont faudrait peut-être inverser
les choses mais je pense que c'est
absolument scandaleux de s'amuser à
faire ce genre de choses on fait pas un
travail citoyen et on donne pas j'allais
dire des clés pour comprendre et pour
aider dans le travail extrêmement
difficile qu'ils ont à faire
frédéric dabi cissé c'est un vrai sujet
mais mal mal posé mal posée et surtout
les propos de yann moix sur le sur le
fond de rencontre quasi aucun écho
auprès des français à chaque année nous
testons la cote de popularité des
policiers des gendarmes et des pompiers
elle est vraiment publicitaires même si
un petit dégradée entre les pompier puis
les gendarmes puis les policiers sur
cette cote
il ya un avant et un après 2015 bien sûr
à mettre berrabeh les les ovations de la
police a enregistré lors de la marche du
11 janvier 2015
et puis l'attentât contre après
l'attentât
après l'attentât charlie hebdo et puis
il ya un nouveau regard sur ces
policiers ces pompiers
ces personnes du samu qui sont attaqués
dans ce qu'elles doivent défendre les
populations on a entendu je sais pas si
ça a été vérifiée qu'une équipe du samu
du var board et des gilets pare balles
lors d'interventions et c'est vrai que
dans le discours et l'imaginaire des
français
les policiers deviennent des sortes de
nouveau de nouveau une star de nouvelles
personnes qui défendent le modèle
républicain
ce qui n'empêche pas l'opinion de réagir
aux bavures
parce qu'il y en a mais il ya une très
grande sensibilité lorsque les policiers
sont attaquées ce avec un des promus une
date un dépôt un des premiers sujets de
conversation dans le baromètre match en
mai 2016 lorsque des policiers à paris
avait failli être brûlées vives dans
leur voiture près de la place de la
république où vous le rappeliez la
sphère de viry châtillon
on a une opinion qui est complètement
qui n'est pas du tout je dirais sensible
à la rhétorique de monsieur moix mais
parce que parce qu'il ya de max non
seulement reproche aux policiers d'avoir
peur mais en plus les accuse des pires
violences puisqu'il se réfère à son
expérience à calais qui n'a rien à voir
avec la police du quotidien de vincent
très malade verra peut-être que si les
policiers ont une certaine peur c'est
aussi parce qu'ils ont peur des
sanctions de la hiérarchie de leur des
poursuites judiciaires à la moindre
bavure
en tout cas c'est pas parce qu'ils
manquent de courage comme on le disait
tout à l'heure je pense que s'ils ont
peur c'est qu'ils sont en première ligne
des différents fronts des différentes
fractures françaises
ils sont en première ligne face aux
islamistes puisque à montrouge et une
policière a été tué à magnanville un
couple a été poignardé et xavier juge
les a été tué sur les champs elysées
lors d'un attentat ils sont en première
ligne face à la délinquance
il faut se souvenir quand même de
l'imaginaire créé par certains groupes
de rap dont les chansons étaient
sacrifice de poulet donc des gamins
grandissent avec comme rituel
l'attaquent du flic c'était le cas des
émeutes de 2005 et ils sont aussi en
première ligne face à une extrême gauche
qui n'a pas digéré la manifestation en
parle et frédéric dabi du 11 janvier
2015 où les gens disaient je suis
charlie je suis la police et je suis
juif où le chanteur renaud chante et
j'ai embrassé un flic et cette
réconciliation autour de la police n'a
pas a été considéré comme insupportable
par une extrême gauche radicale qui a
fait ensuite du flic qui est on en a vu
notamment en flammes à des
manifestations le 1er mai en 2010 est
aussi la cible absolue il fallait qu'un
flic moeurs et à c'était à peu près ça
donc ils sont face à ça il se bat comme
ils peuvent
et ils se sentent parfois politiquement
un peu seul puisque on va pas aller sur
la chaîne judiciaire ou sur les choix
politiques de les aider ou pas mais donc
il y a des raisons légitimes de se
sentir comment dire est isolé et de
portes d'avoir le sentiment de porter un
fardeau qui est celui de défaillance de
notre société qui peuvent ils peuvent
pas tout régler ils peuvent pas être la
figure du père à la fois la figure de
l'autorité d'un c'est pas possible ils
sont là pour faire le l'ordre public
normalement donc je pense que leur leur
désarroi ou leurs tourments sont tout à
fait légitimes
autrefois et pas des flics certain sens
c'est bien parce que vous faisiez la
comparaison avec les profs en dix ans
les jeunes profs comme les jeunes
policiers ne choisissent pas là où ils
vont et c'est eux qu'on met en première
ligne est ce que disait vincent triple
devillers aussi valable pour les profs
c'est peut-être qu'on leur demande trop
mais les considérants de policiers comme
aux enseignants de régler le désert
médical en scène sa nuit c'est bien
pourquoi c'est pas parce qu'ils sont
isolés c'est parce qu'ils sont en
situation d'inquiétude de grands risques
et qu'ils ont pas envie de prendre ces
risques là en ayant fait dix ans
d'études c'est un vrai problème il
s'agit pas de dire que les problèmes
n'existent pas mais c'est absolument
scandaleux de dire tant que des profs
c'est des fainéants qui se met en congé
de maladie ou que les policiers sont des
gens qui manquent de courage et
bon pour le dire élégamment ce que n'a
pas été le cas de max voilà c'est ça qui
est absolument scandaleux ce qui veut
pas dire que le problème n'existe pas
bien sûr pro valorisation des des
salaires justement dans les zones les
plus les plus sensibles y était
clairement insuffisante encore en baisse
pas le prennent de l'expérience le
problème des moyens geste qui fait qu'il
faut renouveler ce jeu suit de l'effort
particulier qui a bien évidemment et je
pense qu'on prend bien le problème à la
racine en commençant dès le primaire dit
blanc caire est un ministre qui quoique
segment je pense qu'il ya un élément qui
ajoute à cette crainte et qui participe
peut-être même d'une angoisse qui
dépasse la police ou les pompiers qui
est un élément presque de civilisation
c'est à dire quelle est cette société où
les gens qui viennent sauver d'autres
gens dans un incendie ou dans 1 dans une
agression se font eux même agressé et ça
là il ya quelque chose il ya des règles
normalement il ya des bandits à d il ya
des flics mais là et on avait publié
dans le figaro un grand ensemble sur les
pompiers il ya quelque chose
d'absolument déroutant quand on voit que
des personnes qui vont risque de leur
vie pour sauver d'autres personnes
risquent même leur vie par les voisins
ou qui les intéressent et je pense que
ça participe ça pour le coup d'une
inquiétude qui traversent la société
française bien au delà de la police est
très fortement ressentie par les
français lors de la catastrophe sncf de
brétigny ou des pompiers qui cherchait à
sauver des personnes avaient été
attaqués par des meilleurs cdc des
moments qu'ils avaient faux couple
marqué l'opinion vous le disiez le les
images ce week-end de ses personnels du
samu du département du var présentant
leur gilet pare balles blanc comme le
com comme leurs tenues de blues a
beaucoup frappé sur les réseaux sociaux
on vous a posé la question de savoir
s'il fallait que yann moix soit
poursuivi pour ses propos comme le
demandait une policière de la de la bac
à gérard collomb vous êtes très
majoritairement en faveur de poursuites
judiciaires à 72% contre yann moix
quelques commentaires sur ce point anti
mac qui nous dit je ne sais pas s'il
doit être jugé il a la liberté
d'expression quoi qu'on pense de ces
propos mais il doit être remis à sa
place
tandis que guillaume nous dit avec
humour yann moix devrait faire un stage
avec la police nord coréenne pour
relativiser ces propos puisque yann moix
enseigner le français voilà l'universite
corée du nord
dernier point ce que vous pensez que les
réponses judiciaires sont les bonnes
quand se pose sur ce genre de polémique
un sens très mal là où là la liberté de
parole doit être moi je pense que la
liberté de parole comprend la bêtise
donc est la vulgarité
si une fille malheureusement donc on
répond plutôt par une forme de civilité
et par le silence c'est à dire que comme
vous avez bien fait de pas diffuser ces
propos et il faudrait qu'on entend moins
cette semaine le budget de 2010 neuf
donc le budget de l'année prochaine